this screenplay is adapted from your
friends book yes so even though it's
about you know a young man and his
father and a family I suspect there's a
lot of you in this story what do you say
to that yeah I think for every director
you have to find yourself in the stories
that you make so definitely I mean it's
the springboard is Sir Francis memoir
for sure he and I were both big
Springsteen fans have been since I was
at school as well as him and that's how
we became friends because if I said read
an article by him on Springsteen I got
turned on to him when I was at school at
school I had a Saturday job at Harrods
in the record department and I was there
I was really into Stax music and soul
music and one day this english chat with
long hair and a long beard said oh my
have you heard of Bruce Springsteen and
I said yes bum not a rocker
I'm not into heavy metal and he said oh
no he's not heavy metal but I thought he
was you know he kind of looked like that
person and then he pulled out the album
Born to Run and he said you should you
should have listened to this and when he
pulled out the album for those of you
who know I was like what and this was a
white dude and a black dude being very
pally with each other very friendly all
smiles and I was really taken aback by
that image because for someone like me
that was a very rare image so that's it
was that image so I thought what's this
story that's what got me into it and
that was a time in England you know
where it was they were turbulent times
you know right from the 70s on as the
father says you know Enoch Powell was
making those speeches of you know
anti-immigration speeches and kind of
sounds familiar that was going on in
England then and
I think that there was this big divide
because our parents the immigrants II
know from the 60s they were 56s you know
they were they had a back home to go to
but we were from England we were the
born raised in England so it was a time
when everyone was trying to work out who
we were
identity wise so that's why that image
was so potent for me at that time and
then I went to see him in 1985 and then
safra's and I became friends and he said
he's gonna write this memoir and then
when I when I read the memoir I said
this is a great memoir I know how to
turn it into a terrific film safra's but
without Bruce Springsteen there's
nothing never got anything and he's
notorious about not giving his music
obviously so how did you get the boss to
buy in so in 2010 we're very lucky he
came to London for the premiere of the
promise and I got invited because by
then Bend It Like Beckham had been a bit
of a hit and so I was I was invited I
took Sarah as my plus-one and we both
sort of stood on the red carpet like
waiting for Bruce to come by and we
didn't really have much of a plan we
just thought we might be able to talk to
him at some point but as he came down
the carpet we both turned into these
like terribly nervous fans and as he
came in he spotted sufferance so as you
saw Sarah has seen him like a hundred
times but not only that he's hung around
outside hotels now we call it stalking
there was no word for it back then he's
a fan felon but he's always outside cars
and hotels and you know trying to get
that little signature but Bruce walks up
says to surf friends hey man
I read your book is really beautiful and
safra's
oh my god it's just starts have a
meltdown I don't expect that did not
expect that so how did you read it who
came at you like that and I'm like okay
be professional be professional you've
got three seconds to do a movie deal
with Bruce Springsteen right now and I
just went hi I'm so glad you're here
sake let you love the book we want to
make a film of it I'm gonna direct it
please really support us we need your
help and he looked at us both and when
sounds good talk to John behind him was
John Landau and Barbara car and Traci
nurse his managers and as Bruce was
whisked away John went what are you guys
talking about what is this then we
change exchanged yeah emails were tres
eNOS and kept in touch and that's how it
all started when we sent him the script
the word came back from Tracy nurse and
she said he's read it and I was like oh
my god what does he think and the
characters the story the songs what does
he think and she said he just said I'm
all good with this and I said what does
that mean
and she said well it means he's all good
with this I think they called it a green
light what does that mean I said does
that mean I get a song cuz can I use the
songs cuz I need the songs no Louis
grinned and she said he said I'm all
good with this so take your let us move
on right I still couldn't cuz those of
us who know these songs custom limit
fortune yep right and I had 19 of them
in the film did so I just had to check
again and said how can I use all the
song use will it be okay and Tracy said
go make you freakin movie see cities oh
good with this and that's literally what
happened as you then developed it did
you ever sort of feel
like the specter of Bruce was oh my god
you know we might worry did it influence
you or you know how did you deal with
that as you made it well I knew that we
had to write a script that he would like
mm-hmm that was the first thing I went
and raised the money and started working
on the screenplay
initially with safra's and then I just I
took over really and said right I need
to make this work it was it happened at
the same time as bricks it and when
bricks it happened in England it was it
was really scary and really upsetting
because overnight it was like someone
switched the xenophobia switch on we can
understand yeah videos going viral of
people getting on buses and shouting
abuse at elderly black women who'd
worked in our hospitals I mean it was
really it was the fabric of society was
just crumbling around me and I was
getting very very upset about this and
the context for me was you know my dad
who sadly is the dad impending like
Beckham and he died before the film
before so I made that film actually for
him but before that my dad had been very
upset in England and he said whatever
you do you must open a bank account in
India and I was like why no this is home
and he had been really disturbed by
former Yugoslavia and the fact that
ethnic cleansing had been happening on
on our doorstep really in Europe to a
mass scale and and I just sort of
dismissed him as a no dad bla bla bla
but then when this when this moment
happened with brexit it really was oh my
god is this what people really think and
feel and and it was disturbing you know
especially if you're a parent and you
have kids you know and I thought I need
to do something about this what can I do
to show the other side
I don't believe people are like this I
don't believe the majority of people
think like this and I think the problem
is is that politicians that can't always
get on platforms and speak about the
positivity of diversity because it
sounds soft you know especially when me
haters and the right-wing have the
platform's mhm you know and have the
airspace and so I thought right the best
thing I can do is make a film about this
to show the other side the antidote and
then that's when I took over the script
and I poured all my anger and
frustration and fear if I said a phobia
basically and what I was seeing around
me and breaks it into this movie now at
the same time over here they'd been talk
of a wall going up but that was about it
everything that happened after that
happened after the movie so it's
incredible to see how you know relevant
the film is not just here other
countries as well where there's a rise
of the right the vet he's wonderful and
how did you find him and how important
was it that he could sing um he it
wasn't important that he could sing you
know because it wasn't a musical like
that right you know the meet the singing
is all very realistic mhm and some of
the singing was appalling appalling and
because they were often singing with
Bruce in the headphones they thought
they were singing in tune right oh my
gosh yeah I had to do a lot of ADR
and some it was really bad but he wasn't
supposed to be a singer and with vivec
he came in any auditioned you know and
I'd seen him on a TV show before I think
what it is is just something about new
talent but I find appealing because they
trust me you know he trusts me my he
still at college he's left now he's
dropped out but he was acting school in
Wales
and and I just saw something in him same
spark vie sirene Keira Keira Knightley
and Aaron taylor-johnson I have to say
but I think with them Vivek I think he
there's an instinct that I see
then less then I feel like okay are they
gonna trust me on the journey and then I
bring my experience to them what they
lack I then try and bring that to them
and you know which is sometimes what you
know what you don't know you don't know
you know so they might not know that
they're not experienced enough you know
so it's our job it's certainly my job to
instill that confidence in them and take
what I saw as the spark of their
intuition you know and pull that out
into a cinema performance so I did work
you know quite extensively with him and
we have a little notebook of his journey
but I couldn't have done it without the
fact that he he had fantastic instincts
and so I was able to go on the journey
with him to create that performance we
thank you thank you so tell me snake
doing